[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the boys
releasing on Amazon this week I thought
I'd check out the dark side of
superheroes to break down everything
that you need to know about season one
and it's ending in the same month at
Avengers end game surpassed avatar at
the box office
the boys deconstructs the genre to show
that depending on your point of view
every villain could be a hero and every
hero could be a villain throughout this
video I'll be recapping the majority of
season 1 as well as giving my thoughts
on the finale of the show and what it
could lead to there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch all of the episodes yet
and don't want to know what happens then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into my breakdown of the
boys season one of the boys takes on
many perspectives throughout its 8
episode run and the show centers around
a group of superheroes known as the 7
that have pretty much become celebrities
due to their powers and lifestyles
similar to our world heroes have
infiltrated every aspect of society and
it's difficult to escape them it
showcases that worship without question
and for lack of a better term fanboying
grants people with more power than they
should have and means that they are no
longer held accountable by the law this
is a clear satire on both Marvel DC the
Kardashians Harvey Weinstein and there's
even several shots at Disney and the
corporation's behind the heroes that
have pretty much turned them into
commodities to be bought and sold that
doesn't mean that the super-powered
beings are innocent either
and the boys exposes the dark side of
those who possess great power and it
showcases that they don't have all that
much responsibility I guess absolute
power corrupts absolutely and we learn
that they all pretty much sex crime
celebrities that use their positions to
abuse the law and silence anyone who
stands up to them this comes to a head
when a regular dude named Huey sees his
girlfriend Robin killed in front of him
due to the blunder of a speedster named
a-train who smashes right through her
faster than you should smash the like
button on this video but do taste a as a
train doesn't really face
any real consequences and this sets off
Huey on a reluctant quest for revenge to
egg down the super humans with his ally
Billy butcher played by Karl Urban
Berkshire has a vendetta against the
seven after their leader had an affair
with his wife and she went missing
shortly after and he begins working with
the CIA who realized that if the Supes
are given military jurisdiction then
it'll be worse than the CGI in Justice
League this is very much a David versus
Goliath situation and throughout Huey
constantly seems like he's in over his
head as he rushes to take down fort the
corporation that have licensed the
heroes - movies TV shows games and
probably Funko pops everyone has a
fungal part these days right I want a
definition Funko pop if the Queen can
get a Funko pop I want a definition
Funko pop anyway the show is about
choices and throughout huy similar for
the 7 is given the option to do the
right thing or give in to his vices time
and time again
luckily for viewers Huey always tends to
go with the red pill or the blue pill
what look whatever pill at what the
other pill and this leads to some
entertaining takedowns of the 7
throughout the series mirroring this is
starlight a parody of Power Girl who
realizes that the 7 aren't the people
that she initially idolized and just
because people love a team-up it doesn't
mean it's for the best after she's
sexually harassed she becomes cynical
and similar to Huey Bowser take ba & Co
down this involves her going toe-to-toe
with Madeline Stillwell the shadowy CEO
of Ord who is the master manipulator of
the entire season
Starla is very much the embodiment of
the meeting movement and she cements
that the only way to rise up against
oppression is to stand firmly against it
she slowly picks apart the patriarchal
society and shows that nails that stick
up are often hammered down she begins
dating Huey who uncovers the truth
behind the 7 and their ties to a super
drug known as compound V this was the
drug that a train was on when he killed
Huey's girlfriend and they slowly
unearthed that it's the formula that is
used to create super-powered beings it's
not just for that are using an either
and they also discover a young female
that has been caged and experiment and
unto and she eventually ends up joining
them realizing evidence of this could
bring down public perception of the
group with the help of starlight he and
the boys do whatever they can to get
hold of it in order to expose the dark
side of the Supes however their attacks
and star lights public stance soon draw
the attention of the higher-ups and
their overlord homeland heir who makes
Brandon for bright burn look like
teacher's pet and he soon begins
striking back homeland it's a twisted
version of Superman and Captain America
that pretty much embodies many of the
criticisms about the USA and it's
self-interested the detriment of others
he's brash arrogant and will step over
people just to get to the top and
throughout he's pretty much the
character that you love to hate after
refusing to save the lives of the doom
fight he uses this tragedy as a reason
to equip the army and invade other
countries and this becomes a clear for
for the Iraq war after the events of
9/11 whilst homeland ax was said to be
an alien that came to earth it's
actually revealed that he is also in
fact a government experiment that was
made in order to market superheroes to
the masses he's a marketing ploy like
all of the other Supes and well I don't
want to spoil too much just yet his
overinflated ego eventually leads to his
downfall
anyway there's reality TV confessions
and an appearance by Haley Joel Osment
that will have you six sense tingling
and overall the season gets you really
invested into both sides it's revealed
that homeland a-- actually impregnated
butcher's wife and she'd hair carrying a
baby with super-strength it apparently
killed her from the inside during the
labor
he's also told that the baby died during
the birth but the Superman discovers
that this isn't true and this betrayal
and cover up by his quote-unquote owners
begins to slowly make him descend into
madness the CIA also have enough
evidence to blackmail Baugh into
retracting their military application
however they soon realize that several
other countries also have access to be
due to homeland as black market dealings
and thus they cannot go public as it
will weaken the position of America's
defense against the new super
homeland er has created an arms race
that means he will forever be needed but
she learns of Stilwell's connection to
him and realizes that she is his
weakness and takes her hostage homeland
there isn't one to play fair though and
after he brings Madeline's baby to the
standoff he reveals that it wasn't him
who killed butcher's wife and there are
still things going on that he doesn't
know about homeland the burns through
Madeline's head and no amount of having
a mother named Martha is gonna get
butcher out of it so he sets off the c4
attached to Madeleine
but unfortunately for him a home lander
is too fast and takes him away from the
explosion to reveal that his wife and
homeland his son are both still alive we
get an awesome Star Wars s cliffhanger
and the show goes out with a lot of
questions so what happens next
well huge spoilers for the comics here
and homelands eventual fate so if you
don't want to know anything about the
future of where the show could be going
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now whilst the story does highly alter
the timeline of the graphic novels with
Madeline out of the picture
I think homeland a will has sent further
within thought and this will mirror his
comic or Kiley in the books homeland
that eventually turns more apathetic and
he sent insane after he's shown some
photographs of atrocities that he's
committed even though he has no memory
of them feeling like he has no other way
out he assumes high command of
everything and attacks the White House
homeland has wished to create an
uprising and this is why he armed others
with vie and eventually he goes on to
kill the president in order to rule the
country himself however it's revealed
that black noir is a clone of the
character created to kill him should he
ever step in his final few moments
homeland realizes that he could have
actually been a hero had he not been so
easily manipulated by others homeland
dies at the hands of noir who was
eventually killed by butcher I can
definitely see this being the direction
of the series head sin with butcher
eventually attempting to get back his
wife and having to deal with the fact
that there's a new member of the family
juxtaposing this wilds homeland that has
a child with Becky it's through force
and she is out now killed by the fetus
which is then beaten to death by butcher
so it seems like the show is heading in
a completely new direction now many
people have been wondering what happens
to Hughie and how he gets out of saving
a train at the end
well in the graphic novel series he too
gains incredible powers and abilities
after he's injected with compound B I
think this will be brought into the
second series as his gal of jail free
card so that he's not hunted and killed
that's easily as he would be without it
he's definitely the wild card of the
show and I can see season two focusing
on the fact that he now has become the
thing he hated and once more he has the
choice to go either the right or wrong
way no doubt with starlight at his side
he can do good and the two could
actually become the superheroes that the
world both needs and deserves down the
line either way there's a lot to look
forward to with the boys and I can't
wait to see how the changes affect the
season going forward what I love about
the series is that it feels like it's
riffing a lot off the Snyder verse which
I actually really enjoy but this builds
on all of the faults of that and turns
them into an interesting and at times
shocking narrative I can't wait till the
boys are back in town sorry that was a
terrible joke and season one scores a 9
out of 10 for me obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the boys and what
your favorite moment of season 1 was I
haven't even mentioned the Simon Pegg
part that's a tie-in to the original
graphic novel and yet there's just a lot
to cover so definitely leave your
thoughts in the comments below I'm also
interested to see what people prefer out
of this and the Umbrella Academy to drop
your opinion on that as I'd love to read
it if you want to come talk to me
directly or just see my general thoughts
on movies TV shows and games then make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey i also just want to
let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of avengers endgame on blu-ray
to one lucky winner and all you have to
do is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the boys in the comment
section below the winner will be chosen
at random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from them to
ever get surprised so best of luck to
everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for take the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]